now though I want to bring in elas
Farhat you're a former Lebanese Army
General there have been developments on
the border between Israel and Lebanon
you're joining us live from Beirut um
this is the other front that we're
looking at today there are multiple
fronts but this is one of them and we
had we got pictures just a moment ago of
the Border area between Israel and
Lebanon and a large chunk of it was on
fire after what a appears to have been
some kind of attack maybe start by
putting that in context for us that area
why that is a flash
point uh actually this fire is not a
result of a fighting the fighting has
been uh occurred when few group from Jad
Al islami
infiltrated uh near the village of Thea
and South Lebanon which is adjacent to
the Lebanese Israeli borders and they
crashed with an Israeli Patrol they uh I
mean seven Israelis were being hit
and it's not known exactly how many from
the AL Jihad Islamic group were dead or
or went away so uh now this fire is has
been uh with has been occurred after
this Clash but I don't think that uh
both sides used the used the Lance
Flames or something like this in order
to cause this flare it these scenes are
from the Israeli side and not from the
Lebanese side you see uh so there is no
uh battles or uh conflicts or uh clashes
in this in the size of causing such such
fire elas earlier today the Islamic
Jihad a short while ago in fact the
Islamic Jihad claimed responsibility for
some infiltration or infiltration
attempt from Lebanon into Israel uh
Israel responded
um by killing the people who tried to
infiltrate who tried to get into Israel
from what was apparently the Islamic
Jihad group how significant of a
development is that for
you yes this is in the terms of uh
warning of hisbah and its allies the
Islamic Jihad and Hamas that the uh
Northern front is ready to intervene if
uh Israel escalated in in Gaza and if
the uh ground offensive uh has will take
place into Gaza that means that the
northern front will will start uh and
Israel will uh be in a danger of uh
fighting on both FR fronts which is both
fronts which is difficult for such an
army the the maneuver on the on the
front uh uh on the home Homeland front
of Israel is narrow so the the the
manover of forces moving forces from
north to south or from south to
North and supports from here to there is
difficult in Israel so many drills the
Homeland command had
had done recently and it it proved that
it's difficult for any Maneuvers so I I
don't think that Israel can uh can fight
on both fronts and north and uh
South elas farad joining us from Lebanon
thank you very much I want to turn to
Ali Hashem Ali you're joining us live
from Southern Lebanon where um we're
still trying to figure out exactly what
happened so what is the latest
information that you
have
well let's start with hisbah announcing
that three of its Fighters were killed
today in Israeli air strikes and this is
very significant because we know that
whenever hisb Allah's Fighters are
killed hisbah vows to revenge for them
and this means tomorrow or maybe tonight
midnight uh in the coming hours there
might be a retaliation from hisbah and
this is going to take things more
towards tension and escalation
the situation over here in southern
Lebanon has been escalating gradually
tension is escalating gradually the
situation of War and Peace isn't anymore
no war no peace isn't anymore here and
people are kind of concerned that
Lebanon is being taken gradually into
this conflict um we saw today earlier
today a group from the Islamic Jihad
infiltrating the um borders and uh
Crossing towards an Israeli settlement
where they engaged in a in a battle with
Israeli uh uh Army uh two of the uh
Palestinian Fighters were killed one of
them was able to come back to Lebanon um
following following this attack or this
infiltration Israeli uh um army started
um raiding several Lebanese
cities there were several air strikes on
Lebanese CI uh sorry towns on the
borders uh the the town of Yin the town
of the town
of and among what they hit were hisbah
Observatory posts and as I just saidah
now announced that three of its Fighters
were killed so this is the picture from
South Lebanon now also in in parallel um
the Israelis were uh hitting some open
spaces some agricultural lands and now
there are pictures coming from the area
there especially from the Israeli side
of of the border of huge fires taking
place there and this is aimed mainly on
preventing fighters from using the grass
the trees the agricultur lands to
infiltrate into the Israeli territories
all right so this is kind of what's the
best word for it some kind of
Preparatory for lack of a better word
maneuver or defensive maneuver by Israel
is what you're saying um
you explained very clearly to us just a
moment ago that with three Hezbollah
Fighters having been killed there is
potential here for an escalation now
until we found out that three Hezbollah
Fighters were killed it appeared that
the messaging between Israel and
Hezbollah was let's actually not
escalate this too far when you look at
what Hezbollah hit when you look at what
Israel's retaliation I'm talking about
events yesterday it appeared that both
sides wanted to keep this relatively
contained and if I understand what
you're telling us this may now
escalate well things go out of control
and this is what's happening right now
yesterday attacked the Posta in she
farms and they chose the she Farms
because it's a a land that's uh claimed
by the Lebanese government as Lebanese
land and hasah says that has the Mandate
from the Lebanese government to fight
that actually it's disputed even in
international law so uh hisbah chose
that land in order not to escalate the
situation however to send signals and
messages and they said that clearly uh
on uh the the the one of the main
officials senior officials Hashim Safi
spoke that clearly on TV he said this is
a message and Israel should understand
the message however things are
escalating escalating and and today with
all these events and the killing of
three heah members it seems things are
going out of control gradually the same
as we are seeing the the tension
escalating gradually things are going
out of control gradually and this is
driving the Lebanese uh uh front uh uh
step by step into this conflict and
giving this conflict a new dimension
because it's not anymore contained
within uh uh this Gaza Israel uh uh
confrontation however it's now taking a
kind of a semi- regional uh uh status
and this is the dangerous thing here no
absolutely Al shazir is alih Hashem
thank you very much for that reporting I
want to draw the our viewers attention
to uh one more time to the scene in uh
Southern Lebanon Northern Israel that
big fire that we saw and Ali was
explaining that's a defensive military
maneuver by Israel to deny uh any
potential cover for armed group groups
operating in that part of Lebanon this
here burning Ali was explaining burning
the grass burning the trees so that that
can't be that area can't be used as
cover